the rhythms of a general election are
well known the campaigning the exit
polls the awkward people standing about
in sports centers but how do you get
there and how do you win
first things first the mechanics we only
have a general election when Parliament
is dissolved that doesn't involve acid
it just means the Parliament comes to an
end thanks to a pretty annoying bit of
legislation called a fixed term
Parliament's act for which we could
forever thank the Liberal Democrats that
can happen in a few ways either the
Parliament reaches the end of its fixed
five-year term naturally without
interruption but this one that's due in
2020 to the Prime Minister can lose a
motion of no confidence they have now
tabled a motion of no confidence and no
other government could be assembled Oh
Prime Minister could just ask the one in
the old days this was very very simple
they would come to the palace and ask
for an immediate dissolution of
Parliament and thereby a general
election these days it isn't her Madge
he has to ask but Parliament the act
says an early election can only be
triggered if two thirds of MPs vote for
one or 434 of them ìiím reality you need
the both the Tory and labour parties to
agree that's what happened in 2017 when
it all started to go wrong for tourism
and I have just chaired a meeting of the
cabinet where we agreed that the
government should call a general
election in the current circumstances
that only seems likely if the PM agrees
to send the election date another weird
power he still has before brexit day on
October the 31st so you've got the
election then what well then Parliament
is officially dissolved or no more MPs
they can't put those magic letters after
their names they can't use their offices
and their staff become unemployed the
government however continues there is
still a prime minister a chancellor Home
Secretary and the like because the
Queen's government must always go on
however government doesn't continue
entirely as normal there's this thing
called perder persian for cloak whoever
said british politics was off-putting
huh it's basically just a set of rules
which means that a government cannot do
anything which might unduly influence
the election or take major decisions
which might bind their success and so
for example taking major spending
decisions
then you have the campaign that's a five
six or seven week period for how do you
win Britain is divided up into six
hundred and fifty constituencies each
constituency roughly with seventy
thousand voters each returns one MP to
the House of Commons they're elected by
a system called first-past-the-post
nothing to do with horse racing every
voter gets one vote only and the
candidate who receives more votes than
anyone else wins doesn't matter they
don't have a majority of the vote even
if it's just one more vote than the next
person
they are the winner the aim of the
election is to get a majority more MPs
for your party than all of the other
parties put together at a magic number
for this House of Commons is 326 if you
do that you are automatically the
government and your leader becomes Prime
Minister if you don't you come second
then you become the opposition and your
leader becomes leader of the Opposition
historically that has been the beauty of
the system its simplicity one side wins
one side loses one side governs one
opposes until they all play again but
recently it's got a bit more complicated
because well mystical parties and
politicians are starting to become very
bad at winning elections if no party
wins a majority then we have a composite
then parties must try and form a
coalition as happened in 2010 with David
Cameron and Nick Clegg Dems daddy why
are you spending so much time with this
man Nick leg or something short of full
coalition were a smaller party
guarantees a government state in office
in exchange for certain policy
commitments or money like Tereza made
and a DUP those arrangements can be
stable or they can be very unstable in
other countries it happens a lot in this
country
you haven't got as much experience of it
and our politicians really don't like it
and if you can't make something work
chances are the country will end up
floating again as happened in the two
elections of 1974
so get ready Britain we're voting for
the fourth time in five years and I for
one couldn't be happier